when I first started teaching online my
boss said to me you'll have online
office hours in the evenings I said ok
online office hours how does that work
this was quite some time ago so she
showed me goto meeting I think we had
one login for our whole University and
we'd use it from time to time and
stagger our office hours and I would be
lucky if two students would show up if I
gave a challenging enough problem maybe
two students would come to see me at the
agreed-upon time that we discussed on
the discussion board and that got old
pretty quickly so I want to share with
you what I have kind of optimized as my
plan for office hours and I'll just dive
into that and I'm gonna show you this on
Blackboard Collaborate but every meeting
software I know zoom is really popular
right now every meeting software is
going to have these features available
so you'll be able to do all the things I
showed you you may just need to Google
for your particular learning management
system or meeting software but I'll get
you going with just some ideas to have a
really successful and interactive
session with your students so in
blackboard I'm gonna navigate to course
tools open Blackboard Collaborate ultra
and when I get there it looks like this
you'll have to search for all this
functionality and how to use it in your
learning management system the built-in
conferencing for canvas is called
conference and then if you have a zoom
meeting you're gonna have all of these
tools you'll just need to get used to
where to find everything so if I click
on this tab over here this is some
controls and this tab expands the chat
so they'll always be a chat and the way
I've set up my sessions the students
actually chat to me and I speak into the
microphone for larger groups this is
just much easier the questions can come
in and I can finish what I'm saying and
keep track of it there's not a lot of
people talking over each other now if
the student needs to speak because it's
just a complicated question they'll just
type in the chat that they want to speak
so let me just put something in the test
I can see how that works and so when I'm
starting and setting up my by default my
audio and video are off it's usually
that way with many of the software's you
start with everything turned off but
just make sure you know how to navigate
that as the moderator you can also mute
other people's microphones so if
somebody's in there and you hear them
like cooking dinner or while they're
trying to attend your office hours you
can go ahead and just turn that off for
that user so the students will tell me
if they need to speak but they're really
comfortable just chatting with me and so
there are some settings that I can
control here to set up things properly
all of my attendees will show up here I
used usually keep this on the chat
except for when I want to start sharing
my content and so when I share that I
usually share my whole screen um there
is a way to share an application but I'm
trying to teach my students how to use
ChemDraw at the same time and they say
you can't see some of the menu items so
I just usually share the whole screen
and so now it says it's sharing and I
can hide this panel it makes this crazy
thing like when you have two mirrors
next to each other really wild but it
lets me show my desktop and I can pull
up what I want to which is a chem draw
file with a little lesson and practice
problems so this is the way I've gotten
them engaged
I said come to office hours you don't
need to do anything you may need to be
honest with me about how much reading
you've done so I know how much I need to
cover as background but you don't need
to prepare anything just come ready to
learn and you might need to answer some
questions for me
and so they'll answer the questions in
the chat and so here is something I just
set up ahead of time this is an office
hours I did a few weeks ago actually
it's kind of a mishmash I'll show you a
few things this is all medicinal
chemistry so I wanted to show them how
ligand might interact with a receptor I
wanted to go over these definitions I
didn't trust that they had done they're
all there reading and I was correct and
so we needed some of these definitions
to get going
and here's kind of what the finished
product looked like I was trying to show
them how there'd be a conformational
change we talked about each of these
definitions I pause to give them time to
think about it and type back to me some
of them you know are slow typer so it
feels like you're waiting forever but
give them that time and it actually will
say something down here like so-and-so
is typing and so you can kind of wait
and just give them think time it's
absolutely fine if there's silence for a
while you could even cut it out of your
video later if you wanted to but then
I'll go into something here's just one
of the book problems and so this isn't
receptors this was just another problem
that I was doing with enzyme mechanism
so this was inhibition and this is a
screenshot from their textbook that I
have the electronic version of I put it
in there went over all the steps of the
mechanism and this was the question
these are both mechanism based
inhibitors explain why so I left them
with this on the screen sometimes you
got to make it a little smaller and so
they could ponder it they could take
notes on paper I think I gave them about
seven minutes of thinking time for this
problem and then we went over each of
these and you know I'll type in some
things I'll show them what step of the
mechanism in ChemDraw use my my arrows
and things like that to show them you
know how things are inhibited and
whatnot so I can draw and mark this up
and make notes for them which I usually
do in blue for this answer key and then
I can send this out to the class if I
want to so here's an original problem
and yeah these are all from different
weeks but the this blue was added in the
session so the students were having a
little bit of trouble getting going and
we're gonna look at what these different
functional groups the kinds of
interactions that they might have and
how you might change the molecule alter
the molecule to see if you to probe for
different interactions let's say and so
we got to this point I was like not
really much going on and I said okay
let's identify some of the functional
groups we might test so we got this a B
and C in here I said okay there might be
others so I'm just gonna put a little
d to the side for now that you and you
can think about this as you go and this
was actually a beautiful example because
my students we're all typing to each
other in the chat when I gave them the
work time I was just watching them
collaborate in real-time sometimes
they're quiet and they you know they're
working it out on paper or maybe they're
totally lost waiting for seven minutes
to go by but it does give them time to
grapple with it and try to write down
something but this class was just really
interactive and their typing back and
forth and it was really great to see and
so eventually I'll put in some of their
suggestions I'll ask them okay how did
you want to alter a and they'll tell me
what they did take out the methoxy okay
what are you doing then and so we can
get into some of those key pieces now I
record this and all their typing would
be here and there is a way to record
through the system and all software's
have a way to record your meeting but
I'm using a secondary program ScreenFlow
to record this because what I found is
I'll actually cut this part of the
screen out because the students they'll
be more likely to offer up responses
because they know I'm going to cut it
out I'm not gonna show everybody what
their wrong answer is so they can feel
free to propose wild ideas or just try
it and say something because they know
that I'll cut it out now if you do that
every question that's asked you have to
very deliberately read it aloud and then
answer it but I'd like to do this
because then if I want to reuse a video
or maybe I just explain something better
than I've ever explained it in my life I
can chop that part of the video and give
it to another class use it for years to
come as a mini lesson because this was
the best time I've ever recorded me
going through a problem like this so one
thing I want to share with you is how to
create a live stream on YouTube now I
know at my current University they've
been saying you don't use Blackboard
Collaborate for lectures like it just
takes too much bandwidth it's supposed
to be used kind of infrequently for
office hours but a YouTube livestream is
a great way to record
a live session the students they'll only
be able to type to you through a chat
but I mean if that's all the
functionality you need and you really
just want to record yourself doing
something but have them there and then
have it available for other students you
can start a live stream so let's create
a live stream so we'll go live and we'll
just call this test and we're going to
set this to be unlisted so anybody with
the link can view it like next oops and
you can see my microphone so we'll get a
thumbnail and so that might just be you
there and so now you can go live and you
can share it using this link so we'll go
live and now you can see how we can
interact like I just have a whiteboard
behind me so if you have a whiteboard at
home and you want to draw things out you
could go ahead and make sure you make
sure you draw them large enough so that
people can see and maybe with a better
marker and less glare but you get the
point of what you can do with this and
you have a chat over here so people
could be asking you questions as you go
you could write for a minute then check
your questions and respond to them so
that makes this really nice and if
you're already in it you can also get
your share down here again and I'm just
gonna go ahead and end this stream for
now I hope this video gave you some
inspiration for ways that you might
interact in a synchronous way with your
student and maybe some ideas to make
your office hours nice and engaging
thanks again for joining me